we interesting to see you know with the
next group because they're obviously
really different like they don't want
big giant houses and all that stuff that
you know sort of my generation and your
generation thought that so you think the
new generation is different in their
values and what they do right they say
that they they give more they volunteer
more I think the tricky thing for them
is going to be connection and being able
to be connected and being able to have
real conversation and you know even be
able to concentrate long enough to be
with somebody because of devices yeah I
mean I think it's far could you imagine
right now if you were twenty know and
being like dating and swiping and trying
to pay attention and or even ten you
know my daughter is one of the few girls
in her closet doesn't have a cell phone
what's the age did they get him like
them since they were like seven no I
mean you're right kids like what's the
rule in your house there's a debate all
right now let's figure it out well okay
so you have a ten you're gonna be 11
yeah I think that they say there's like
a movement wait till 8th yeah you heard
that yeah like ten kids in the class all
the parents agree so they're not the
only person in the class that doesn't
have it but it's not that way with my
daughter's kids the kids in her class
most of them iPhones most parents just
give the kid a phone yeah it's just
there's uh have you read any of Jonathan
hates stuff the coddling in the American
yeah of course and that that is just so
disturbing when you see the amount of
especially young girls that are growing
up depressed cutting themselves so harm
what's that like four hundred percent he
said like from ten to fourteen or
something crazy like something insane
massive spike that directly coincides
with the invention of smartphones and
social media yeah the slot machine yeah
it's this this thing where people are
just trying to get likes and trying to
leverage their you know their social
status and and try to pretend that
they're living in a perfect world to
everybody around them and everyone else
is doing it and people look at other
people's lives being perfect and they
reflect upon their own they get
depressed there's just so many factors
that kids didn't have to deal with just
a decade or so ago it's really off right
like at least if I had a hard time at
school I could go home and have a
reprieve from it
overnight I think for me that's that's
been a thing with my kids is like
especially daughters I do think I
understand the gaming is different for
boys and porn pornography and things
like that and that whole trip of
rewiring their brain and but I think
with girls it's like how do you get them
to under don't know how they're gonna
get to a place where they I mean cuz
every it's like this weird mish-mosh of
like me too and then never before had
people objectified themselves more
because they again them that positive
affirmation like I always say if I put
out really smart ideas if I'm a young
woman oh I have a thousand followers
every shot is of my but I have ten
million followers so we have this mixed
message going on which is like I'm angry
me to treat me equal simultaneously to
I'm going to objectify myself in the
most hardcore way more than in any time
in history attack the results and its
really but for me as a female who
understands both those sides a little
bit I kind of trips me out because I
don't think you like those girls you
know playing that card and have no
violence should be done to you and I
agree with all of that and no is no and
all of that but at a certain point you
know like you've had Jordan Peterson on
here many times it's like biological
signaling it's like what I play a side
at least and also that oh that's that
one side is super short-lived that's
what I try to tell my girls I'm like you
listen if you're you know you're pretty
girls it's great but if that's the card
you're playing your cards done like by
the time you're 30 35 it's done it's
over I mean you know unless you're like
14 you marry a seven-year-old I don't
know or whatever
giving the MILF porn is that such a
thing yeah yeah but even that it's like
they got to put a filter on it and like
all that stuff I mean come on how do you
get these girls to go hey stand up for
yourself be strong but like what are you
doing but look at all these people that
are not
doing that that are benefiting I know
but it's getting them to understand how
do you get a thirteen-year-old to talk
about the long game right I mean
everything's immediate but for me it's
like it's culturally I feel like I'm
this weird mix of like the most i came
through at the most modern time like
women went to school and on scholarships
and like we there was no thought to
being like strong not really and then
but then weirdly it's like I feel so
kind of old-fashioned when I see kind of
this next thing because I'm like well
strong for me was something else strong
was like you were really physically
strong trying to have a strong mind you
know strong basis of a person and then
okay then there was this other side like
your femininity your sexuality all this
other stuff and now it's like I don't
know I it's very interesting well
there's certainly a bunch of different
kinds of people right and there's gonna
be people that gravitate towards
objectifying themselves
that's kind people that gravitate in
this day and age towards you know you
see a lot of people's pages are just
filled with motivational quotes and
inspirational things and you know and
the stories about people that they meet
and photos and you get a lot of people
that are attracted to that kind of stuff
too it's just you're not gonna get the
immediate gratification of a picture of
your ass that picture of your ass it
gets a hundred thousand likes like wow
look at all those likes yeah and then
you know it's just a different vibe and
you have to decide what are you after
you have to quantity or quality or after
you trying to accurately Express how you
feel and work it out through
communicating with people and figure out
how they react what you're saying and
how you feel about how other people say
similar things and how it does good
things for you and you want to do good
things for them or do you just want to
yeah so a piece of dental floss up to
crack your ass
yes sticking it in front of the camera
this you know no and I get that like I
get also like I always say when you're a
young woman you sort of get this new car
and you're like well what happens like
what if I put my foot on the gas like
you're sort of checking it all out like
they respond like this if I do that like
that's completely natural but then at a
certain point I don't know that the
input is like you know like who do you
want to be and not based on what
everyone thinks about you like what
actually
turns you on and and makes you feel
excited and stoked because you know it's
great that you have a nice butt but
there's a lot of nice butts and in the
end that's not probably gonna bring you
that other feeling the problem is that
there's a thrill to positive reaction
absolutely and that thrill is undeniable
I would like it to old people and when
people get that thrill then you tell
them hey that thrills bad for you you
look fuck off mom no no I mean a bolt on
to that message how about not like get
the thrill but simultaneously to doing
the thrill maybe have some other
thoughts about where you where you'd
like to continue to journey - yeah but
you know I think when you tell that to a
thirteen-year-old they hear it
eventually yeah I think in the beginning
like yeah yeah I got this
yeah and later when it all goes sideways
like god damn I still listen to mom yeah
I think you just gotta be it too and
have some like cool friends that hang
around you because you're if you're the
parent it's like okay you're gonna
penetrate so much but if you've got some
like you know in Hawaii they call them
auntie's if you got some badass chicks
around you and your daughters are
looking they see right they say but what
if you don't have access to that I have
a lot of pretty strong cool women around
me but that not that it concerns me I
don't want to say that it's just how do
you help the next group you know try to
be a good example love on them but get
them to teach them to love on themselves
right that's all and I don't mean with
eyelash extensions and like perfect
things I mean like love on yourself yeah
you know well that's the other thing too
this is a distortion distortion of
natural beauty and to you know make it
so that everything has to be artificial
the colour of your lips the color of
your eyeshadow fake lashes
everything is just that doesn't it
doesn't look better just looks different
do you think I I'm always fascinated
what men think like do they even like do
they does it even register do they know
what's going on in what way well I guess
we'd have to ask men of that generation
if
let's say they had two groups of women
and one that was like perfectly quaffed
with the lip injection quaffed oh is it
yeah I like that I'm talking about like
eyelash extensions with Jo but like just
sort of really done like ready for the
club let's just say and then just like a
girl like hi I'm you know I'm a sweaty
runner and now I'm gonna go to the
office and put my hair up in a ponytail
I don't know whatever if guys if they
even can they tell the difference yeah
for sure
yeah yeah I mean it's all what you're in
what you're into yeah yeah some guys
just like I'm soft and made up some guys
like I'm sweaty and muscular yeah no and
I get all that I love that I just mean
again it's hardcore signalling and I
guess that's maybe that's what it is
maybe it's the new biology well it's
also that there's never been a time like
I got a bit on one of my Netflix
specials were about this girl who's got
just pictures of her ass here like 9
million followers on Instagram like he's
never been a person like this before
this is a new kind of personally fuck
fuck
looking at these frogs in the Amazon
that no one's gonna say there's a new
kind of person yeah this girl just has
pictures of her butt and she's got
millions of people staring at her all
day long and every day is just new
pictures of her but it's a great point I
was intrigued how they decide like oh
we're gonna do the butt on the beach now
let's do the butt next to the puppy it's
like I'm so confused how they keep
getting ideas I can't even four
different things and it's like I know
we'll do but with the cotton candy it's
like okay I don't know I think it
becomes a obsession I mean I think you
have to stay fresh with new butt ideas
is that you're just like editor envelope
editor
I know do you do hey in the head butt
editor here but at but calm I don't know
but if you have a girl who has let's say
some of these girls have millions and
millions of followers and they're making
millions of dollars you're crushing it
yeah maybe they're actually the smartest
people in the room and I haven't caught
on yet it's certainly an easy path to
finances I know right if you have a
great ass and you like working out
anyway
you just want to take pictures of it
I'll sudden you have 25 million
followers like damn but this goes also
ok we do quite a job no definitely not
cuz nobody she can say well I'll do the
right thing and work at the library I'm
not suppose it's just I mean if it was
my kid I'd be like you know sweetie you
might want to weigh out the economics on
this right I think you said something
really important it's a whole new thing
yeah and I think however it's sort of
like the communication you're always
having which is well what is success mmm
and for me it's that's all it's like
getting people encouraging them whatever
that is whatever that looks like you
know you said this like oh you do this
show whether anyone was listening or not
most likely right probably I mean until
you couldn't afford it anymore let's
just say but obviously I would do it
just to have the conversations I'll do
it right maybe I wouldn't do it as much
but I would definitely do it right if I
had it like if someone said hey you know
every few months of physicists or come
in here and sit down with you for hours
it like yeah let's do it
that's what I want to do yeah well
you're bringing information to you and
learning to you so for you part of your
definition that success yeah and so I
guess that is the conversation because
we always have this thing that's obvious
thing of like success is it either is
notoriety its power its money and then
we forget those other communications
about like the pursuit of something that
really genuinely turns you on well I
think people get short-sighted and you
definitely can get success we just have
money and you just have objects you have
notoriety and people will view it as
success but if you're not doing what you
love it's not pure success it's a
different kind of success like if you
really find something that you enjoy
doing and then you take that like Laird
has with surfing or many people have
with their passions and then you become
successful through that it's a different
existence because it's an it's a pure
existence like when I do stand-up comedy
or if I do like commentary for the UFC
it's a very it's a pure enthusiasm yeah
it's genuine comes across I don't have
to fake it it's I enjoy doing it that's
to me I don't I know everybody can't do
I know everybody feels like they can't
do that or they haven't figured out a
way to do that yet right but if you can
if you can if there's a thing that you
can do like maybe I would have made more
money if I went into the stock market
may be able to made more money if I was
a banker maybe I don't know right but I
definitely wouldn't be as happy there's
no way if I'm the same person I am now
and I was in a fucking office all day
making a hundred times as much money I'd
be miserable right and I think that I
guess for me that's maybe when I see the
thing with the girls and like I said
feeling sensitive to it because I have
daughters or just young people in
general it's that conversation of like
you know just keeping that definition of
success open and by the way this other
path that taking it like following your
own instincts or desires or passions
there's elements to that that are our
heart are harder for sure it's more
unknown you can feel insecure like is
this the right thing to do I mean we've
gone I mean in our house we've gone
through that 50 different times you know
it's like I'm gonna do this because I
really want to I don't know what's gonna
happen right and I don't know if it's
gonna be successful I might even lose
money and who knows but that once you
start to do it or you do it once or
twice then you go oh but it's so worth
trying if